je note en souvenir de libye ce que tu
vas nous dire est très important c'est
ben qu'à tuer ta maman était seul
j'avais 8 ans quand elles sont mortes
tout d'un coup j'étais célèbre hu libido
allez-y par le moto club
le petit club c'est simplement un petit
groupe qui aime les affaires de meurtres
non résolus
des détectives privés des juristes des
assureurs d'anciens flics on est lucide
des crimes
c'est notre truc si vous et votre petit
club voulait me faire gober que ben est
innocent vous perdez votre temps j'ai
apporté dossier vous pourrez le
consulter
vous êtes loin d'être bête vous verrez
vite qui est un truc pas net dans cette
affaire et a bien foutu ma vie en l'air
sous là j'avais 11 ans il voulait qu'on
reste tous les deux après la classe
bonjour je cherche un certain ronald ten
c'est le moment de dire la vérité sur
les meurtres sont arrivés à leur trouver
tu verras vous savez s'il a une nana une
histoire sérieuse
et bim ans et plus sur 10 en pointe nord
ouais je sais pas libye je ne sais bien
que tu finirais par me trouve à les voir
ben tout commence avec l'une ans avec
lui tout se termine et les indiens train
fait com - laisse tomber tu vas tout de
même encore longtemps je te dis de ces
tomber
il ment sur dur grâce est notre seule
certitude pourquoi tout le monde ment ça
arrive
une fois que tu seras la vérité tu seras
en paix
c'est bien triste pour toi petite fille
je t'emmerde connard tu trouve ça drôle
non je trouve ça ironique quoi tu vis en
prison toi aussi